j'ai vu justin bieber hier tout le monde
voulait voir tout le monde voulait le
voir et je suis allé voir il partait
parce qu'il enregistrait le grand
journal hier qui passera demain
d'ailleurs un sur canal+ pourrait voir
justin bieber demain mais là j'ai
attrapé et je veux dire il s'est passé
quelque chose je crois on sétif et
regarde you musique ilike et lala lala
lala lala deux ou trois heures el mago
talent
allez salut salut frérot comme en salle
qui fait justin ça lui ferait rostock
qui tu pars avec tout fait rond et
attend ya pas ma carte bleue dans la
liste je sais je crois qu'à ma carte
bleue y en a mais être mortelle [ __ ]
ma pitcher ma carte bleue et mais un
mail est cool j'aime beaucoup ce garçon
j'aime beaucoup
parce que s'il devait partir en fait de
son buteur et la vanne avions dix
minutes après ils m'attendaient le
pauvre dans le hall c'est un amour
vraiment parce qu'on est en train soit
là mais il a voulu me foute a pas il est
vrai je vous le jure il est vraiment
parti et que ma veste n'enrichit pas
bien mes parties n'ont heureusement il y
avait en fait j'ai laissé ma carte mais
c'est ma carte génie pour aller retirer
et est vraiment super sympa le gars
qu'on a parlé un petit peu avant mais
comme le cadre arrêté au point de
prendre un café rhône n'a pas pu filmer
donc mais sans rigoler cadreur et je
sais pas où il était on fait il est en
train de se servir du papy brossard au
et voilà et après donc il est arrivé
donc on est en train de discuter
tranquille voilà en tout cas justin
bieber sera demain au grand journal de
canal+
oh